[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine de la semaine de
européenne des mobilités donc c'est
l'occasion de mettre en avant une
dimension particulière de la stratégie
de développement durable qu'on a sur le
sur paris ça clair sur ce grand projet
international que l'opéra paris saclay
porte avec des enjeux urbains des enjeux
de densité proximité avec la avec les
transports en commun capacitaires avec
des enjeux énergétiques avec des enjeux
de biodiversité
donc effectivement cette dynamique
globale sur le développement durable qui
tient à coeur de l'ensemble des équipes
de le pea il ya la dimension mobilité et
aujourd'hui c'était l'occasion de mettre
en avant un enjeu fort parkin sacré
c'est la première application mobile
digital est connecté dédiée au
stationnement sur parking c'est clair
elle vous permet de connaître en temps
réel l'ensemble des places de
stationnement disponibles sur le campus
urbain paris saclay avec la possibilité
d'avoir les places en voirie mais
également des places réservables chez
nos barques une partenaire en parking
partager il vous suffit de vous rendre
sur parking saclay point fr pour accéder
à l'application vous aurez
automatiquement accès à tout club de
stationnement temps réel sur le plateau
de saclay puis si vous souhaitez
réserver vous pouvez créer un compte et
ensuite accéder au parking en
réservation à la cahc télécommande
virtuelle qui sera disponible sur
l'application
aujourd'hui on supervise plus de 150
places sur le quartier de l'école
polytechnique et sur la zone du moulon
nos deux principaux partenaires sont edf
et centrale supélec chez qui vous
trouverez des places de stationnement
disponibles
on va dire que la notion de
stationnement dans les villes est un
véritable enjeu
sous les immeubles de bureaux les
stationnements sont plaints la journée
vie de la nuit sur les îles de logements
celle inverse ou assez facilement qu'une
certaine mutualisation permettrait
d'optimiser la quantité de parking
construire donc d'optimiser la quantité
de matière de travaux à réaliser et donc
d'optimiser aussi l'impact l'impact
carbone donc cette dimension de
mutualisation parking saclay maintenant
opérationnel vous pouvez obtenir sur sur
internet à naples et l'application et ça
vous guidera vous aidera à vous guider
vers des places de parking libres nous
avons fait un bêta test de cette
exploitation pendant les pendant l'été
on rentre dans une phase opérationnelle
et l'objectif c'est que au moins 1000
places mutualisée au mois de juin et
c'est pendant pendant quatre ans on va
encore continuer pour optimiser voir
comment ça se développe
[Musique]